oh thank you
i opened the bottle and i poured myself
a shot
and drank it
missouri was
flinging insults
left right and center and
she then grabbed that bottle
and uh
and threw that
at me
i honestly didn't i didn't feel the pain
at first at all i felt no pain
whatsoever
what i felt was
um
i felt heat
i felt heat and i felt
um as if something were dripping down my
hand you know
um and then i
looked down
and realized that the
the
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
i i
i think that i
went into some sort of
i don't know what a nervous breakdown
feels like
but that's probably the closest that
i've ever been i didn't
nothing made sense
and i knew
in my mind and in my heart
this is
this is not life
this is not life
all right you're ready for the jury yes
okay
mr deb have you ever physically
assaulted miss heard never
have you ever sexually assaulted miss
heard
never
certainly not
what have you lost as a result of
misheard making these allegations
against you
nothing less than everything
or once that happened
i lost
then
i will live with that
for the rest of my life
because of the allegations and because
it was such a high profile case
so
i lost then
no matter the outcome of this trial
i'll carry that for the rest of my days
and uh
it never had to be that way it never had
to happen
and i don't
quite understand why it did in the way
that it did